hello everyone welcome to another
episode of science and technology q a
for kids and others
and i see we have a bunch of questions
either saved up from last week or
submitted on our form
i also gather that there's now a bot
that's announcing uh
these live streams on twitter so
pay attention to the bot
like
uh
as opposed to
i'm thinking of
i'm thinking of wizard of oz but that's
not very relevant
um
in any case let's see
questions here okay there's one from
peaceful here
asking can i explain why
earth's air doesn't escape into the
vacuum of space considering that gas
expands to fill the available volume if
it doesn't have a container
okay that's a that's a interesting
question it's
uh
should be famous last words should be a
fairly easy piece of physics to explain
so
in in a gas
there are molecules that are
going around in random directions and
molecules in in typical air molecules
collide the the distance between
collisions actually very short um these
molecules are always colliding they're
always going in random directions
and if the gas
if you don't have any container around
the gas these molecules will eventually
they'll go into some random direction
where they've never been before they'll
expand out and and that will make the
gas expand out so the molecules will end
up going in the random direction to the
if you don't have a container there well
what do you have instead maybe you have
a vacuum where there are no molecules at
all and that means whenever a molecule
gets to the edge of the place where
there are lots of other molecules it'll
just keep going because it isn't
colliding with anything and it'll expand
outwards into that vacuum
so the question is and that's what
generically happens with with a gas
and the pressure of the gas
is
the amount of the
when when the gas has pressure that
means it's pressing on
some container that it has
and the the pressure pressure is the
force divided by the area so it's the
and the pressure is determined by the
number of molecules that hit
the uh the edge of the container every
time when a molecule hits the edge of
the container it bounces off it's kind
of like a mirror it's or it's like a
billiard ball hitting the side of a
billiard table it's the molecule hits
the the container depends on exactly
what the container is made of exactly
how the bounce happens but then
basically it bounces off
when it bounces off
its momentum is going in the direction
towards the the edge of the container
because otherwise it wouldn't be going
in that direction
then that momentum is turned around it's
going back in the other way and when
that momentum is when as it's turned
around the molecule is pushing the edge
of the container out to conserve
momentum because it's um uh
that's that's newton's third law it's
it's every action is an equal and
opposite reaction or in other words
things when when when you it's like uh
if if
you're
there lots of different effects that all
come down to the same thing um where
momentum uh that is the momentum of the
molecule is reversed and so that
momentum is is uh is transferred to the
to the walls of the container and so
that's what leads to the pressure of the
gas is molecules hitting the wall and
bouncing off
and the pressure
is proportional to well basically two
things the number of molecules per
unit of volume
and the speed of the molecules
and well also
i guess the mass of the molecules enters
in some way also
but um the speed of the molecules for
example
is proportional to the uh
temperature temperature is determined by
the average energy of the molecules and
kinetic energy is a half mv squared
where v is the velocity m is the mass
and so that means that the the
temperature
and the pressure are related
okay so why does the gas
not escape from the earth
well the answer is
those molecules that are going
uh out
that are trying to escape from let's say
we think of the the atmosphere of the
earth as just a giant box of gas
and there is no
on the on the surface of the earth
there's a solid surface and when the
molecules hit it they bounce off but
when the molecules are going out towards
space
there's no boundary there so you would
think the molecules would just keep
going but they don't why not
they don't because of gravity because
molecules have a mass
and like anything else with the mass
they get
affected by gravity and so molecule is
going out it's going out it's it's
trying to make it outside the earth's
atmosphere and uh the
eventually it will just get turned
around by gravitational force and it
will get pulled back towards the earth
again
and so the real question is is the speed
of the molecule in the gas
larger than or smaller than the escape
velocity of the earth
so if you if you just shoot a rocket up
from the earth's surface if the rocket
isn't going very fast the earth's
gravity will just pull the rocket back
down again
there's a critical speed at which if the
rocket is going that fast it can escape
the gravity of the earth that critical
speed for the earth is 25 000 miles an
hour
and so if you shoot a rocket and it gets
above 25 000 miles an hour it can escape
the gravity of the earth and it can uh
go as far away as it wants if it's less
than that eventually the rocket will get
pulled back down by the by the earth's
gravity and so it's the exact same thing
with molecules
so
in fact the molecules in
uh so then you have to ask well how fast
do the molecules in a gas go and as i
was kind of explaining the speed that
the molecules go at is determined by is
related to their energy and their energy
is related to their temperature
um and so if as soon as you have
molecules uh in this gas
not going uh for example in gas at um uh
at room temperature
the um uh the molecules are basically
going
in air are more or less going at the
speed of sound that's not terribly
surprising because sound is compression
waves in the air
and
if that we know that the maximum speed
that you can get a compression wave to
move in the air is the speed of sound
but that's also the max the speed that
the molecules are going at and if you
wanted to like send some signal through
the air
as
represented by
the the pressure of the air the the the
compression of the the air clearly
that's it's not going to be possible
ordinarily to have that travel faster
than the the um uh the speed at which
the molecules are actually moving and
bouncing around in the air so the speed
of sound is is related as actually
factor of group two as if i remember
correctly um between the the speed of
sound and the uh speed of the of the
molecules in in the air
so
that the speed of sound
is uh about
600 miles 650 miles per hour i think at
um at standard um at sea level and so on
at standard temperature and pressure um
and uh so that's much less than uh the
um
that's much less than the escape
velocity so molecules that if you took
molecules from sort of the
you know from this room for example and
you you tried to get them to escape from
the earth's gravity they wouldn't escape
from the earth's gravity now okay so
there's a tricky point which is that
the
uh
uh
at let's see how does this work
the um see this is always the problem
these questions where i think this is
really simple um i realize wait a minute
i have to explain i have to think
through something
and it's not quite as simple as i
expected
but
one feature of the earth's atmosphere is
that the most common gases in
earth's atmosphere nitrogen and oxygen
but in the universe as a whole by far
the most common element is hydrogen
followed by helium and so the question
is why isn't there hydrogen and helium
in the earth's atmosphere
in the atmosphere of jupiter it's mostly
hydrogen
and so why is it that jupiter manages to
keep hydrogen in its atmosphere and
earth does not
the answer is the escape velocity of
jupiter
is uh much higher than the escape
velocity of earth
the and what happens is
at and this is where it gets a little
tricky and i i have to think through how
to
how this works and how to explain it but
essentially the point is that a hydrogen
atom um
on
the hydrogen molecule on the earth
can
uh
at a certain temperature
will be going fast enough that it
achieves escape velocity for the earth
so it escapes from the earth so probably
the very early earth did have hydrogen
in its atmosphere but after a short time
every time there's a hydrogen atom
that's sort of going out towards space
it's going fast enough that it can
escape the gravity of the earth and it
just dissipates into space but for an
oxygen atom it doesn't succeed in doing
that and the essential reason for that
is
that the escape what matters to escaping
from the gravitational field is the
escape velocity
but what matters the temperature is
determined by the kinetic energy um and
that uh
that's a weird thing
the um
the uh
um
and the but the um
uh
uh kinetic energy
is proportional to
is mass
times velocity squared and so that means
that if the mass is
uh for a given kinetic energy if the
mass is lower the velocity will be
higher and so that that's that's why
that if the mass is lower like it is for
hydrogen as compared to oxygen you know
the mass of a hydrogen atom
is basically one atomic mass unit
whereas the mass of of um uh
um oxygen is
16 atomic yeah that's right 16 atomic
mass units so oxygen is 6 times 16 times
the mass of hydrogen so that means that
it will be its
velocity at a given temperature
will be with the the square and all that
kind of thing it will be a quarter the
um the the velocity of the hydrogen atom
and that difference is the difference
between managing to escape from the
earth's gravity but not a state from
jupiter's gravity for a hydrogen atom
for a hydrogen molecule
um i'm i'm cheating a little bit here
because the hydrogen molecule which is
h2 and just a few bits and pieces of
formulas and things but that's the basic
idea the basic reason that that um the
atmosphere of the earth does not escape
is because it's held to the earth by
gravity but some gases uh do don't um
end up with their molecules going faster
and so those do escape and that's why
you have different uh constitutions for
the for the atmospheres of different uh
planets of different sizes
so let's see there's a question here
that sort of relates to what we're just
talking about from william
asking why are there phases of matter
are the phases real or do they depend on
what we can observe okay that's a that's
an interesting question which starts
elementary and then has a has a a big
hook to something quite non-elementary
all right let's let's talk about the
basic question of phases of matter
so
you know one nose for water or something
there are basically three forms in which
water can come ice solid liquid water
and gas steam
and
the what what is the difference between
those phases
well
in we kind of know intuitively what the
difference is in a solid it all moves as
one block
and you know it's kind of hard to deform
and if we look microscopically all the
atoms or molecules will be kind of
arranged in a fixed array
in a gas on the other hand at the
opposite extreme
the molecules are all separate and
they're all just bouncing around and
they're randomly colliding with each
other liquid is an intermediate case
where the thing can kind of if you try
and sort of squash a liquid it's
typically very hard to squash if you try
and shear a liquid it typically has a
resistance to being sheared significant
resistance to being sheared but
nevertheless it can flow in a way that
is uh uh that where where the liquid
pieces of liquid can go sort of anywhere
so to speak they're not they're not all
in one block
okay so why do things work this way why
are there for example three phases like
that
actually it's more complicated than that
because there aren't uh for solids for
example there can be many phases so for
example a okay so in in
okay in cases where
the
there's several different kinds of
solids
the most common kind of crystals
where the atoms are all arranged in a
very regular array so for example a salt
table salt sodium chloride is a is a
crystal
and you may notice if you look at the
little little pieces of salt that
they're cubes
and the reason they're cubes they're
usually cubes at least the reason
they're cubes is because inside that
salt crystal there are lots of
sodium and chlorines and they're
arranged in this regular cubic array
so if you look down at sort of a
microscopic level you would see
something which is kind of like lots of
lines of of atoms that are that form
this kind of cubic array
so for example if you look at something
like a diamond for instance well it's
often a bit confusing because diamonds
are cut in special ways but if you
looked at a raw diamond you would find
it has a certain
and you looked at the carbon atoms that
are inside it you would find they're
arranged in a particular kind of array
that doesn't happen to be quite the same
as the as the sodium chloride cubic
array but different kinds of um there
are actually 26 kinds of crystal
arrangements that you can have 26
so-called bravais lattices um and they
uh they're the different kinds of ways
that you can arrange atoms and molecules
so that they have the feature that um
you can that they're that they are uh
there's one block and then another
repetition of that block and then the
repetition and so on all the way through
the crystal
so what what is happening there well
what's happening is
when
uh
let's see how to explain this
the the fundamental thing that's
happening between these different phases
is
in a solid
the atoms or molecules are kind of more
or less just sitting there next to each
other in some kind of arrangement and
they might be wiggling around a little
bit
as a result of of temperature
temperatures is what temperature is
microscopically
is
the uh
is
the energy of individual molecules so
temperature the formula is
the energy
per
sort of degree of freedom per sort of
direction the molecules can move is a
half think of boltzmann constant k times
t the temperature
that's uh that's
the
the uh so the the average kinetic energy
of your random atom
um
at a temperature t
ends up being three halves kt
so
the
um the thing that um
uh
uh so temperature
is proportional to the average energy
measures the average energy of the
molecule one tricky thing
uh when you say temperature measures
that when we measure temperature like we
say it's about 70 degrees it's about 20
degrees celsius
here
that word degree
is kind of telling us that this is not
an absolute scale of temperature this is
temperature relative to some zero of
temperature so for example degrees
celsius is measured relative to the uh
melting point of water um the zero
degrees celsius
that's that's the zero of that scale but
there is an absolute scale of
temperature the so-called kelvin
kelvin temperature um and that's
something where
it's um and when we talk about these
formulas where the kinetic energy is
proportional to temperature
that temperature scale is the absolute
temperature scale
okay what what does it even mean that
there's an absolute temperature scale
all these things are kind of connected
the temperature is measuring the kinetic
energy of molecules it's measuring how
quickly molecules are are sort of
bouncing around
uh so then then that suggests that there
has to be an absolute zero of
temperature where the molecules aren't
bouncing around at all where the
molecules where there's essentially zero
energy in the molecules and that's
correct that's that's how it works and
that zero of temperature is about minus
273 degrees celsius
um that's so-called absolute zero at
which in a first approximation
in if you cool things down to that
temperature all the atoms and molecules
that would otherwise be bouncing around
with a certain
kinetic energy they'll all just be
staying still now a little bit of a
footnote they don't quite stay still
because of some effects from quantum
mechanics which i can talk about so
so-called zero point energy um but in a
first approximation and sort of the the
basic physics explanation is when you
get down to absolute zero the atoms or
molecules are just staying still
when the atoms or molecules are staying
still
they tend to uh that that's then they're
pretty much guaranteed to be a solid and
the reason is that there are forces that
cause molecules for example to attract
each other and that means that when you
have these all these molecules and
they're that they have no kinetic energy
they're all pulled together by these
small forces that attract the molecules
together and that means they're all
pulled into this thing that ends up a
lot making itself into this this pure
solid uh usually a crystal
um the the reason that molecules well
uh
yeah there are essentially electrical
forces that cause molecules to always
have a certain force of attraction
between them um and uh it's and that's
what will make them
form into something which is a solid so
at absolute zero
almost everything is a perfect solid of
course there are always exceptions to
things and helium-4 a certain isotope of
helium
is not a solid at absolute zero at least
at ordinary pressure um it's still
liquid there and the reason it's still
liquid is because of quantum mechanics
effects and uh it's it's the sort of the
weird exception
the um
but
most things are solid even you know even
all the gases that we know in you know
the
you know nitrogen oxygen hydrogen
they're all solids at absolute zero
um because the the molecules in them
have this force of attraction between
them and they have no energy to sort of
bounce around
and escape from that force of attraction
okay as you heat things up
there comes a point where those forces
that pull molecules together are
are irrelevant compared to all the
energy the molecules have just as a
result of temperature just as a result
of heat in the material heat
the what heat is is the microscopic
motion of molecules and so
as measured by temperature um and so
when there's enough heat in the material
high enough temperature that means the
molecules are bouncing around and the
fact that there's this tiny force of
attraction between them is irrelevant to
these molecules they're just going
around as a result of the heat and then
they they collide they bounce off each
other
and the fact that there's a force of
attraction is basically irrelevant and
that's what happens in the gas
and so when you increase the temperature
of material enough
it will turn into a gas okay footnote if
you increase it even more it will turn
into a plasma if you turn it if you
increase the temperature even more the
electrons inside the atoms will get
stripped off the atoms and the thing
will become an electrically charged
plasma but that that's what happens in
fire for example but in ordinary
materials the sort of as you increase
the temperature it will turn into a gas
okay so as you cool it down
eventually those forces of attraction
between atoms and molecules and so on
get large enough that
it condenses into a liquid
the process of condensing into a liquid
is even after all these years not very
well understood liquids are really hard
to understand in in terms of sort of the
mathematics of what's going on in a
liquid
but
what tends to happen is the gas will get
to the point where there are forces that
will cause the atoms to kind of stay
together but they can still move around
a bit
okay then when you cool it down further
the thing will uh
freeze into a solid
and at that point the the forces are
strong enough that they will just keep
the atoms sort of or molecules kind of
locked together
now
often
there if you say well let's take carbon
for example you know in what way can
carbon atoms be arranged well one way
they can be arranged is a diamond
lattice where there's a particular
crystal arrangement that makes diamond
another way they can be arranged is a
graphite the kind of thing you find in
pencils which is a very sheet like
they're arranged in kind of sheets of
atoms
and both of those are perfectly valid
solid forms of carbon they are different
phases of carbon
um they're different solid phases of
carbon
and so many things most materials that
become solids can have many different
phases
and usually those phases uh
when when you change the pressure for
example you'll get a different phase a
different arrangement of atoms different
arrangement molecules so for example
water has i don't know how many phases
on but about 10 phases that are known of
solid phases
and most of the time
we don't notice those but a glacier for
example which is water at the bottom of
a glacier for example there's a very
high pressure because there's all this
force from you know lots of lots of of
ice on top pushing down on the ice
underneath and so the phase of the of
the you end up with the
molecules of water arranging themselves
in a different way and so you get a
different phase of ice there
and in fact phase changes are important
for example in the rocks that make up
the earth um there are many different
phases of the rocks
and sometimes phase changes um i'm not
completely sure what the latest theory
on this is but but it certainly used to
be believed that phase changes were
important in earthquakes
um and that that was one of the things
that could
as as you change the pressure of a rock
you can change the phase that the rock
is in and when you change the phase when
when you change the solid phase as the
atoms rearrange themselves the for a
given number of atoms the volume that
those atoms can take up may change and
so for example you crush the thing hard
enough and suddenly the atoms will
rearrange and the thing will become
smaller it will have a higher density it
will have a higher mass per unit volume
but it will become smaller when you when
you crush it um because of the
rearrangement of the atoms and that can
lead to potentially some discontinuous
change in in the in the structure of the
rock and
may give you an earthquake or whatever
else
but so
okay so so then this idea of solid
phases there can be multiple ones
as
as you heat the thing up the the atoms
start they jiggle around a little bit
but they stay more or less in their
place
and then eventually the thing melts and
the molecules start moving around kind
of randomly in the water
and and then when you heat it up further
the molecules escape the water um and uh
and the thing becomes a gas so a
question you might ask is is there only
one liquid phase or could there be
multiple liquid phases well nobody knows
the there have been claims every so
often that there are multiple liquid
phases and there are some situations
actually with water water is a
particularly complicated substance
um are there claims that there are kind
of these these within liquid water that
there are these kind of clusters of
molecules which behave in a different
way from what you would think kind of
the overall bulk liquid wherever every
molecule is moving around any place it
once might be but it isn't really known
whether there can be multiple liquid
phases
with gases
sort of inevitably there can only be one
phase because the the molecules are sort
of bouncing around randomly there's no
kind of arrangement of molecules
now
the question of
um
are these the only phases solid liquid
gas are they the only conceivable phases
well things are more complicated um so
for example
the uh
for example most of what we're made of
is this kind of um
uh as a sort of gel type phase which is
something that doesn't happen
well doesn't normally happen with a
single substance but when you have kind
of the cytoplasm of a cell for example
it's made up of many different kinds of
molecules and it's got water in it and
so on and that is a phase where things
are kind of squidgy but they don't flow
like water um and they don't they're not
sort of uh solid like like a
they're not uh they're not
perfectly solid another thing that's
weird is glass
glass and glasses
um
uh if you
in a glass
uh like a window pane of window glass
um
the the molecules don't form a crystal
they're not arranged in a nice regular
way like they would be in a diamond
uh or something like that um instead the
molecules are sort of packed in randomly
that's the defining feature of what's
called the glass
um is that the well the molecules in the
case of of uh of window gas or something
that's silicon dioxide um and uh the um
uh basically comes from sand um and
it's a it's a version of that
that has uh the molecules just sort of
packed in randomly
and that actually means that if you have
a a
in an in a crystal
the thing is sort of rigidly locked down
to be sort of arranged in that grid of
of positions of molecules in a glass
they're not as rigidly locked down
they're sort of in randomly random
positions and that means that in fact
the glass can very very very slow slowly
flow pretty much like a liquid so if you
see you know window panes that were put
in you know 400 years ago or something
you'll often see that they have
thickened at the bottom because very
slowly the glass has flowed because
these these molecules they're not locked
in place as they would be in a crystal
they slowly can rearrange themselves in
that way
so
a question you might ask is
uh
could it be the case that
there are and i think this is probably
william's question
um could it be the case that there are
sort of phases of matter
that
uh where
the the what we notice about solids
liquids and gases
is
you know from at the scale we're at we
can pick up something that's solid we
can paddle around in something that's
liquid we can uh uh you know we can
inflate a balloon with something that's
got gaseous
and with those ways of interacting with
materials with the ways we normally
interact with materials
um
the it's it's pretty obvious the solid
liquid gas classification is pretty
obvious
but let's imagine that we were organisms
which are very tiny compared to us for
example or which let's imagine we're an
organism
that um i don't know it's a tiny little
organism that has these giant filaments
that come out from it that sort of sense
the the environment nearby
and let's imagine we put that in let's
say water
well it could be the case
that for example this question about the
clusters of molecules in water actually
let's take the more extreme case of a
gas
we think there's only ever one phase of
gas because all the molecules kind of
bouncing around randomly but maybe there
are situations in which there is
microscopic non-randomness in the gas
which a critter
that was you know size of molecules with
all these long tentacles and so on might
be able to sense that we just wouldn't
notice we'd say the gas looks random to
us
so it certainly is possible that if
you're looking for different kinds of
things you will sort of you would
conclude that there were different
phases of matter let's think about that
for a moment the the the question would
be can we imagine
a
uh sort of a a an imaginary organism
that would come to different conclusions
about how
um yeah here's an example
okay so
one slightly odd form of matter is
liquid crystals
so in a crystal as i explained
all of the uh molecules for example i i
keep on sort of alternating between
atoms and molecules because in in
something like sodium chloride you're
not really dealing with a molecule of of
sodium chlor chloride and another
molecule the the sort of individual
atoms are kind of separately in there in
the crystal lattice whereas other things
like water there really is an h2o that's
there and then there's another h2o next
to it um so it's sometimes one's really
talking about things where they're
molecules sort of in that you can
identify and other times it's kind of
atoms arranged in a certain way but in
any case uh liquid crystals
so
in an ordinary crystal uh solid crystal
you've got
atoms or molecules arranged at these uh
in this lattice and this regular array
what is a liquid crystal a liquid
crystal is something where
the
it has long molecules in it
and the positions of the molecules are
moving around randomly the molecules are
sort of bouncing around randomly just as
they would in any old liquid but the the
long
they're long molecules and so they have
an orientation and that orientation can
get lined up
and so
in a certain phase of the liquid crystal
the uh i think it's the spectic phase um
the um
uh
the the all of the um
uh
uh all of i don't remember is that the
right phase or is that the one where it
anyway whatever there's a phase of the
liquid crystal where all of the uh
molecules are lined up so they're moving
around randomly their positions are
random but their orientations are
aligned and for example when we have
liquid crystal displays
the way those work is
when you put um
uh an electric field across the liquid
crystal um
then you can you can arrange for these
these molecules to all line up when
they're all lined up
they don't let light that is polarized
that has its electric field for example
sort of uh wiggling in in one direction
they don't let that kind of light
through the liquid crystal so that means
that when you when you put the field on
the crystal and all its molecules line
up you're blocking some light from
getting through and so that pixel will
look black for example but in a liquid
crystal
then the idea is you've got these um
this alignment of molecules but not
uh positional order of the molecules so
i'm sort of imagining a critter that um
for which the most important thing about
it is
the alignment of molecules and then it's
going to conclude
that
oh for example actually even a more
extreme case okay i got a better case
in in a liquid crystal okay
so
in a fluid
you have vortices so fluid you can the
fluid can flow it has a certain velocity
it's all going in one direction but the
fluid can also have a rotation a piece
that's a rotation you can see you know
in a in a um when water is draining out
of a a tub or something you can see it
forming this vortex
or you can when you just run your finger
through water you'll see behind your
finger those little vortices that start
up whether where the water is
circulating around the big time version
of that is a hurricane in the earth's
atmosphere or a tornado um those are
vortices and in a vortex the big feature
of a vortex is
once the circulation has started up you
can't make the circulation disappear
there's there's no way to just sort of
say oh this air of water that's going on
in this direction on one side that
direction on the other side
those two things you can't sort of
smoothly get rid of the presence of that
vortex it's a so-called topological
defect
um and the only way to get rid of it is
to sort of damp the whole thing out
so
in um
in water for example or an air you can
have these vortices
in liquid crystals you can actually have
more elaborate kinds of structures which
have the same kind of topological
character of of the sort of as you go
around a circle you end up with this uh
sort of
in a sense as you as you go around a
circle
with um uh in a hurricane for example
you can say well the air keeps on
rotating in the same direction around
the circle um and there's a more
complicated version of that this is
related to the mathematics of homotopy
um and these are so-called homotopic
groups
that mean fancy mathematical terms it's
all about pi one of s1 um is the uh is
the thing that determines the fact that
yes you can actually have a hurricane so
to speak is you know the pure math of
that um has to do with kind of the
winding number
can you can you tell
okay so so the way this place this comes
from is imagine you have a piece of
string
you can as you pull on the ends the
thing will eventually get straight
but let's imagine that the piece of
string was wound around a pencil just
once
you pull on the ends it's still wound
around the pencil
okay you can't deform that to get to
something where it isn't wound around
the pencil at all just by pulling on the
ends
let's say you wind it around the pencil
twice it's got a winding number of two
pull on the ends you can't change that
you can't change it to a winding number
of one or three or anything else just by
pulling on the ends you have to unwind
the string and rewind it to get it to a
different winding number there's more
elaborate versions of that when you're
not just winding a one-dimensional thing
around a a sort of a one-dimensional
pencil but where you're for example
here's an example of one this is a
famous one is can you comb the hair on
on a tennis ball
so the question is you've got you've got
this sort of tennis ball it's got it's
it's sort of
furry tennis ball and you ask the
question is there a systematic way to
comb
that
fur so to speak so there'll never be a
defect in the first so you just smoothly
make you know the first going this way
this way this way as you go around the
tennis ball you'll never have a
place where there's a discontinuity
in the direction of of combing of the
fur turns out that's not possible and
there's always a there has to be
somewhere on the tennis ball where
there's a discontinuity in the kind of
towing direction for this hair and
that's a slightly fancier version of the
same winding number question
um so okay so what i'm imagining is a
critter
that where all it cares about is
vortices or generalizations of vortices
and and perhaps the more fancy version
of that that happens in liquid crystals
which is more like the hair on a golf
ball on a tennis ball thing um and a
more elaborate case so the question
would then be
is it the case that you could imagine a
critter where for it the most important
thing is phases that were associated
with vortex numbers and things like this
yes you could imagine that and then its
conclusion about the quotes phases of
matter will be very different it would
say what really matters to me is whether
this water has lots of vortices in it
not whether the water is flowing like
water does or is like a gas and so on so
yeah i think the interesting point i
think that probably is observer
dependent what the phases are and
actually it's a good thing to think
about
all right we're on a kind of a um
uh
a um
a bit of a physics kick here
um
and uh actually parmenides is commenting
that um sodium chloride makes incredibly
square crystals yeah it does it's really
remarkable how
you know
it's an interesting thing about crystals
okay you might say
okay sodium chloride is always going to
make a cubic crystal
for example ice
the phase of ice the most common phase
of ice is a hexagonal crystal phase
and one certainly aware of the fact that
there are hexagonal snowflakes that are
just uh you know just hexagon shapes
that's when
when snow is is very um it's not very
fluffy
then that's usually when it's kind of
icy in things that's when there are pure
hexagons that can slide pretty easily
really relative into each other that's
what the the crystals of ice look like
but we all know that you can also have
snowflakes and they're also ice crystals
and if you looked microscopically at the
arrangement of
water molecules inside a snowflake
they're all perfectly lined up just you
would
as you would expect in an ice pistol
but the outer boundary of the snowflake
is not just a hexagon
so in in the case where the outer
boundary is a hexagon it's kind of just
reflecting the inner kind of positions
of the of the molecules it's just as if
you have a certain arrangement of
molecules and you're stopping at some
point and that outer boundary reflects
the the inner structure of the molecules
when people first started studying
crystal structures about 300 years ago
the um uh that was and people had had
observed them earlier people had that's
probably a
a original kind of motivation for
identifying some of the platonic solids
like like the um uh well particularly
the dodecahedron probably um that um uh
was was seeing that in crystals things
like that in crystals um
the uh the question then
is uh does a does the outer form the
so-called habit of a crystal does it
reflect the arrangement of atoms inside
the crystal or not
well the answer is sometimes it does and
sometimes it doesn't so when you have a
fluffy snowflake a snowflake that has
lots of arms where the arm makes arms
and it's it's making kind of a tree-like
structure usually called the gender
snowflake a dendritic structure after
the greek word dendron for a tree
the dendritic
uh crystal
also microscopically the molecules
arranged the same way but the outer
boundary is not arranged the same way so
why do dendritic crystals form why do
why isn't it the case that once you have
this inner kind of arrangement of
molecules why doesn't that end up
determining the shape of the whole
crystal
again it's a bit complicated and people
it's it's some actually i made some
contributions to this particular
question myself
um it turns out the critical effect is
the following
uh you have to ask how does a new
molecule get added to the surface of
crystal because when a crystal grows
it's got to be it's you know it's
growing a molecule at a time that
like for example
i don't know you can you can grow
crystals out of liquids you can go you
know copper sulfate crystal or something
and it'll it'll you know hang it on a
string from a seed crystal or something
and um it'll gradually accumulate copper
sulfate and you'll find it has this nice
parallel parallelogram type shape that
comes out at least in principle it does
i remember when i was a kid trying to
grow those things they often didn't work
but that's a different matter
um but in any case the the what's
happening in the growth of one of those
crystals is
uh there's the solid surface
a um
a molecule of copper sulfate is hitting
that surface it's getting trapped
because there's forces that attract
attracted to the surface when it gets
close to the surface instead of bouncing
off it just sticks on the surface and
gradually the the solid expands
now in the case of a snowflake as it
forms
if the snowflake is forming fairly
rapidly what will happen is the molecule
will come in it'll hit the snowflake
it'll attach to the surface of the
snowflake
but that process of attachment as it
locks in to that attachment it will
slightly heat the snowflake up right
there and the reason is it had all this
kinetic energy that it was using to sort
of bounce around and as it gets locked
in place that energy has to go somewhere
and that energy gets turned into heat
that heats up the local area right
around the place where the molecule
locked in
and so that heat so-called latent heat
of um
uh that is released by the thing
becoming a solid
um at that point
that heat that's released
will then make it less likely that the
next molecule that comes along will also
stick to the surface if it was right
close to the first molecule and so that
phenomenon one can call it growth
inhibition when when something has grown
in one in a particular place it will
tend not to grow at the exact same place
immediately afterwards it'll take a
little while before things have cooled
down to the point around there where it
can grow again and that's why basically
why dendritic arms form because what's
happening is a little piece of crystal
accretes on one side and then it says
okay i don't want any any crystal right
near me because i just heated things up
and so that means that you'll end up
with this arm that grows out and
there'll be nothing right next to the
arm it doesn't fill in right next to the
arm because as the arm has been growing
out it's heated things up slightly so
that's why dendritic crystals form more
or less there's a nice cellular
automaton model that um
i made up at one point um that uh uh
for that other people worked on it also
um that uh that represents
kind of um uh the basic
essence of the phenomenon of this growth
inhibition thing that leads to this
gender structure and actually does
rather well at modeling the actual
structure of snowflakes because
snowflakes they have arms the arms grow
arms and eventually
if you just look at the geometry of the
situation the arms run into each other
and you end up getting back to a
hexagonal plate but it's a hexagonal
plate there's a few little holes in it
from where kind of arms uh collided um
that leaves certain holes and if you
look at under a microscope and an actual
snowflake you'll see those holes when
it's at the stage where it's kind of got
the arms also have collided so anyway
dendritic crystals are a thing
that um uh is kind of a
it's still the same crystal structure
but the outer boundary of the crystal
the way in which the crystal grows
is by this process when it's growing
more quickly it will grow these
dendritic arms
do dendritic arms matter will they make
snow fluffy that's nice
they are um it's important for
avalanches whether the snow has gone to
a place where where this where most the
snow that's falling is just plates that
are very slippery or whether it's some
dendritic uh uh pieces of snow
that um uh that are not so slippery
another place where dendritic structure
matters a lot is in batteries
um in uh it's the thing that actually
limits much of the the um
uh energy storage in batteries has to do
with the formation of dendritic pieces
inside the material
of the battery um and that that will
then eventually i guess short out the
battery as these dendritic pieces kind
of eventually reach out into different
parts of the battery
um
there are
so anyway that that's some
uh
uh that that's
the so different crystals can have these
different they can have dendritic growth
um or they can have what's called
epitaxial growth which is this growth
just in layers um in in that way now
even when they're growing in layers
things are complicated because for
example i mentioned vortices
when the atoms uh
get attached to the surface you can end
up with these things called screw
dislocations where essentially these
progressive atoms that are added aren't
quite lining up perfectly
they start being off a bit and you can't
get rid of that off a bit kind of screw
shape thing and you form this kind of
vortex like structure on the solid
surface
and so that prevents you from having a
perfect crystal you end up with a
crystal with these with these
these defects in it
um and so for example when people want
to make uh silicon crystals to make
microprocessors it's a big deal whether
the crystal structure is perfect because
to make a a chip with a billion
transistors on it every transistor is
very tiny it's only a
modest number of atoms across the
transistor and if the crystal structure
around those atoms is off a bit the
transistor won't work so it's really a
big deal to try and figure out how you
make a perfect silicone crystal and and
the whole sort of there's a whole art of
how you make good crystals and how
slowly you let them cool down and all
this kind of thing as they turn into
solids there's a lot of different um
different ways to do that it's more i
think an art than a science it's not
really completely known they're just
procedures that people have found that
grow really good crystals but that's
that's an example of where where that
shows up
um
alistair is commenting that that
this whole dendritic growth thing
uh is is how vegetation goes and so on
as well actually a little bit different
reasons the um
the main reason plants grow
dendritically instead of tree-like
shapes
is because
plants have
rigid cell walls they have cellulose in
their cells
and that means if you're a plant and
you're growing you can't like just sort
of uh you know you can't have something
where you grow a little piece and then
that puts pressure on the piece that
grew before you just sort of squidge
into a certain shape a plant is a rigid
thing and so if you want to grow
outwards and for example you want to
expose your leaves or something like
this the only choice in a sense is to
grow in this progressive branching type
way
and
the the mechanics of how that works i
mean that plants
they tend to have these um uh apical
meristems they're called these these
places where you're actually have uh so
there's a growing piece to the plant
where it's going to add more material
and it can't change what's there already
um
the uh um
uh you know once the once the cellulose
cell wall
is uh of the plant which is which is
rigid for the
for sort of crystal like reasons um gets
uh gets laid down the only choice the
plant has is to add another rigid piece
we animals discovered something else we
discovered kind of how to be squidgy
and you know when a piece of us grows
apart from bones which also tend to grow
just at the ends um the uh uh you know
when pieces of us grow you can you can
have like a thing that's that where
you're getting dividing cells and things
are growing outwards and you just
because we're kind of squidgy you can
you can just put pressure on the other
cells and they'll move and deform and so
on rather than you having to have you
know it's a solid thing and it's got to
grow by adding more
stuff to this kind of solid structure
the question here from william again how
perfect to crystals can they be used to
detect microscopic structure of space
oh interesting um
crystals
you can get very good crystals you can
get a crystal like a silicon crystal
where
it is an absolutely perfect crystal
where like a thing you know an inch
square piece of silicon
is perfect not a single atom is out of
place
um
that's uh
now
is there a way to use that
to detect
uh in in our model of physics
in the end
space
is you know people often think of spaces
just like it's a coordinate you just say
where to put things anywhere in space
we believe uh brother increasingly good
evidence that space ultimately is made
up of sort of these abstract things we
call atoms of space that are just
connected in a giant network and that's
what kind of makes that is the stuff
that is that our universe is made of and
that means that at the lowest level at a
sufficiently small scale space is just
discrete things and so in the end
you won't be able to make a perfect
perfect crystal because things have to
sit
you know at the positions of atoms of
space but the atoms of space don't have
a built-in notion of position
their the whole idea of position is just
determined by these relations these
network connections between these atoms
of space and so there is certainly a
sense in which
you can't have
the kind of uh perfect with respect to
position crystal
but i think the issue is that we don't
know what the scale is of kind of the
effective distance between atoms of
space but it's probably
a trillion trillion trillion trillion
trillionth trillion
10 to the minus 100 meters
roughly let's say
and
the actual distance between atoms
is uh uh you know 110 billionth of a
meter for example you know incredibly
much bigger than the distance between
the atoms of space
um the atoms in a silicon crystal might
be uh you know
some fraction of a billionth of a of a
meter apart but that's huge compared to
the trillion challenger and shown
trillions
uh of a meter that the atoms of space
are apart but it is an interesting
question whether you can have enough
atoms
in a crystal that their collective
effects could allow you to detect sort
of deviations um in the structure of
space and that's an interesting question
and i have not thought adequately about
it and uh
you know good good one to think about
thank you
um
let's see
uh there's a question from memes here if
atoms of space act like a superfluous
would that mean there are vortices that
arise if the universe is rotating
oh boy
um
there are definitely
the analog of vortices which can arise
in the kind of underlying structure of
this kind of giant network that
represents the structure of space there
absolutely can be things like vortices
um in fact particles like electrons may
very well be the analog not quite as
direct as just things circulating around
like a vortex but the basic analog of
a
vortex in the structure of this network
i'll give you a bit of an analogy we
don't know exactly how this works but
but um if you have a a network
just a a bunch of points connected
together to make a graph
a graph in the mathematical sense
you you've just got all these
all these points and let's say you
connect them with pieces of string
and then you say can i lay out
this whole sort of tangled thing
with
you know places where the pieces of
string are connected together can i lay
that out so that it is planar
so that there are no pieces of string
ever cross over that they'll never have
to cross over you might have one
arrangement where the by the lots of
pieces of string crossing over but the
question is is there a way with the
connectivity of the pieces of string to
lay it out so that the thing is planar
so there are no pieces of string
crossing over so that's a mathematical
question the planarity of a graph
and there's a theorem in graph theory
that says there's a condition there's a
very definite condition you can state
for whether you'll ever be able to set
up the pieces of string so that they are
purely planar and the condition is that
certain subgraphs certain particular
local arrangements pieces of string
there are that there have to be two
kinds of subgraphs that are missing
they're called k uh k5 and k3 um they're
they're just particular arrangements of
sort of pieces of string arrangements of
the graph
and
that um
if if neither of those
local arrangements is present then you
can lay things out in just a nice planar
way
but
if you have one of those sort of
non-planarities present you can't get
rid of it if you if you rearrange the
string and you you even uh you you even
change the structure of the graph but
always preserving polarity you can't get
rid of that thing and that's kind of
like the fact that you can't get rid of
that you know the piece of string that
was wound around the pencil or the
vortex and the fluid same kind of idea
and it's that kind of local stability
that we think is associated with
the existence of things like electrons
which are essentially in our models of
the universe uh sort of local
uh regions of space that there's a
strange analogy which we don't
understand very well yet there's a
strange narrative between black holes
and particles like electrons it's
probably more than an analogy they're
probably really very very similar kinds
of things a black hole is a region of
space
where the structure of space is such
that for example there are
things can get into that region but
cannot get out of that region it has an
event horizon for example it's sort of a
a place where the structure of space has
become very kind of uh um uh very uh
condensed and there's this kind of outer
boundary which hides everything inside
that region
well the suspicion is that electrons are
very similar to really tiny black holes
um and that they too
can potentially have they they have a
structure just like black holes from
sort of from the outside all you can see
is oh that's a black hole a certain mass
that's spinning at a certain rate the
fact that oh it was a collapsed star
inside and had a whole civilization and
they were uh you know they've got all
kinds of things going on in there
doesn't matter you can't see that from
outside a black hole and and so
similarly for an electron one of the
things that's always surprising about
electrons is that it seems like every
electron in the universe is the same
they all have it's not the case that
it's electron number one electron number
two and they're all a bit different
um well that can happen if sort of
inside the electron there can be all
kinds of things going on but it has kind
of an outer boundary that prevents one
from noticing what's going on inside and
that would be the direct analog of a
black hole although at a very different
scale and that's that's kind of the
suspicion about how that works
and the suspicion is that both of those
things we know for black holes this is
the case but they're kind of uh versions
of kind of leica vortex and space-time
it's not actually a vortex it's a
different different topological
structure but it's the same kind of idea
so
let's see
um
the questions uh
oh gosh um
all kinds of interesting questions here
uh
calais is noting that uh diffusion
doesn't work in space
um and well okay diffusion
is the process whereby
uh
well at least diffusion in a gas
is something where let's say you have a
let's say you've got a different kind of
molecule let's say you've got a molecule
that we could smell as some kind of you
know wonderful aroma or something
well the question is how does that
molecule that is the the
the smelling molecule so to speak
how does it move in the air and the
answer is it diffuses in the air
typically
and what is diffusion diffusion is well
that molecule is here it hits another
molecule it bounces off it goes in a
different direction it bounces off
another molecule it slowly moves across
the room
and actually what tends to happen is
that the distance it will go is roughly
proportional to the square root of the
time that it's it's been going for and
it gradually
and that that process of diffusion
happens and it happens at that rate
because the molecule keeps on hitting
other molecules and the molecule is sort
of randomly made to go in a different
direction the molecule essentially
executes a random walk through the air
through the gas
and that's sort of the rate at which it
goes now in space
there isn't diffusion because there's
nothing for it to hit there's nothing
that will make it walk randomly instead
once you have an atom going in a certain
direction it's just going to keep going
that direction except insofar as it's
affected by gravitational fields
magnetic fields electric fields these
things that are but it's not going to be
like like diffusion in a gas where the
where what's happening is determined by
kind of the the molecule bouncing around
so
uh
that's some
uh yeah so so
uh
the the forces that between molecules
um
so there are different kinds of forces
uh in for example sodium chloride there
are ionic forces an individual atom with
its electrons stripped off has an
electric charge and it will attract
another individual atom and so on the
forces between ordinary molecules just
like a complete molecule are so-called
van der waals forces
and those
arise in the following way
so
when you have magnets
you can have you have
let's say you have two magnets
and those two magnets will have a force
of attraction between them the north
pole of one magnet will line up with the
south pole of the other and the magnets
will be attracted to each other
and and that force is a magnetic force
and the um
uh that's that's a
that's just a force that exists we can
talk about
if we say why does it exist
you're going to sort of drag me into
talking about our fundamental theory of
physics because the the why in
traditional physics is just like that is
a thing there is this there are these
properties of electromagnetism and
that's just the way it works
now
for a molecule a molecule okay so an
electric charge
like an electron for example has an
electric charge
uh electric charges
like charges like two electrons with the
same charge they repel each other
opposite charges attract each other
that's different from the way it works
with gravity with with gravity
like you know masses always attract if
there was a negative mass thing which we
don't know exists but but then it would
repel but but in gravity like charges
like masses attract whereas in
electromagnetism
like charges repel unlike charges
attract
that's in in the in the underlying
physics
it's uh it's not really an explanation
but uh the graviton is a spin-two
particle and mediates gravity and the
photon is a spin one particle and that
is what that's the sort of that's a way
of describing the same phenomenon of
like charges repel unlike charges
attract etc
so in any case
uh
that's how
if you have charged things there's an
electric force between them
if you have um
okay the the tricky trickier case
is if you have two charges right next to
each other a positive charge and a
negative charge they'll be attracting
each other then the question is what
happens to another positive and negative
charge that's somewhere nearby
that combination of the positive and
negative charge is called an electric
dipole it's a two-pole you know it's got
a plus and a minus in it it's a dipole
and what happens is that uh electric
dipoles attract each other and and
that's more or less for the same reason
that magnets attract each other although
it's now an electric force rather than
magnetic force it's basically the minus
part of one dipole is attracted to the
plus part of the other and vice versa
and so they attract each other
um just for the mathy uh you know the
for for electric charges there's an
inverse square law one over r squared
for the force the the um for dipoles one
over r cubed
so
the um
uh okay so what does that have to do
with molecules
well turns out
uh some molecules just have an electric
have a dipole moment they have they it's
as if they they've separated the charges
and they are overall their charge is
zero but they have plus and minus
charges separate actually water
molecules work that way um water
molecules that's one of the reasons why
water has weird properties is because it
has that dipole effect
um but the other thing that happens is
that a just a neutral atom somewhere um
even though it doesn't have any
intrinsically have any of this dipole
thing going on
what will happen oh boy this actually
has a little bit of complexity in it um
what happens is because of quantum
effects
there is continue a little bit of
fluctuation
of well the charge is more or less
equally distributed but there's a little
fluctuation that causes the plus to go
that way and the minus to go that way
just for a moment and then there's
another fluctuation it causes it to go
the other way and so on what happens is
those fluctuations when they occur
they fluctuations occurring in one atom
will induce fluctuations in another atom
and it will induce a dipole moment which
actually is such that these two atoms
will attract so as a result of quantum
fluctuations there is this small sort of
dipole to dipole interaction between
between atoms that leads to this
attractive force that leads to
uh
these even things like liquid helium and
so on being being you know having
having attractive forces between them
um
that was there's more to say about that
but that's a that's a rough version of
that
um
okay there is a question here
uh from brian could
photons be frozen at absolute zero
um
okay so
this whole story of temperature applies
to material objects it applies
temperature is a story of atoms and
molecules running around
uh light is made of photons
and the same story doesn't specifically
well
okay this is a bit tricky um okay so
normally
temperature applies to
just sort of um uh molecules and a gas
running around etc
now actually and i realized i worked on
this myself in the late 1970s um
in the early universe
there are
um
all kinds of other
uh
um there were all kinds of other
particles that existed
and you can define a notion of
temperature for those two and you can
say oh there are electrons going around
there are protons separate protons there
are quarks
there are this there that all these
different kinds of things
were there
and there's a temperature defined by the
the energy of all these particles going
around by the way people asked about
phases of matter and so on um in the
case of of uh of the early universe
there will be a phase at which there are
individual quarks and gluons running
around and then as you cool it down
there's a phase at which
uh it's usually called the ground plasma
and there's a phase as you cool it down
particles like protons and so on start
forming you kind of get these droplets
formed out of this plasma of quarks and
gluons which otherwise is just this
thing that's sort of like a like a gas
or a liquid or something where these
things are just sort of flowing all over
the place and then the nature of that
particular kind of uh system is such
that it always forms at lower
temperatures it makes droplets and those
droplets are the particles we have like
protons and neutrons and so on um but
any case that so there is a notion of of
temperature
for
uh other particles like quarks and so on
there isn't really a notion of
temperature for photons because photons
always go at the speed of light
and
the
this
idea
let's think about this for a second
i mean photons have an energy
their speed is always the speed of light
but their energy is determined by the
frequency of the you can think about it
as determined by frequency the color of
different colors of light have different
energies of photons associated with them
now the question would be
what
uh what is the analog well okay so the
the
okay
so
what's the analog
of a different phase of light
the answer is a laser a laser is the
analog of the solid phase of light
and so what happens in a laser
um
in ordinarily in light
you know you have a incandescent bulb or
something if anybody even has those
anymore um but uh or an led light well
the incandescent bulb is an easier case
to explain you have a hot filament
and
the um
photons are produced by atoms
uh they're released as a as a result of
the the
energy in these atoms gets released in
the form of photons and so these photons
are all streaming out from different
places on this hot filament and it's all
kind of a random arrangement of photons
so called incoherent light
okay photons have an interesting
characteristic shared by some other
kinds of particles but that they're
so-called uh bosons
and
the
particles like that have this feature
that they like to always be in the same
state as their neighbors and they like
to do that for reasons of quantum
mechanics that we're starting to
understand in our models of physics
but in ordinary quantum mechanics it's
just one of those things which it is a
fact that
bosons like to be in the same state and
that means by by same state it means
they're going in the same direction they
have the same momentum
and if you so so here's how that
actually happens
when
you
are thinking about photons bouncing
around
and they can interact with different
things they can go in different states
and so on
the formulae that determine
the
way that that happens
uh it's some well
i guess so-called transport equations
that are determining sort of what's the
number what's the probability that a
particle
will get or bounce with a certain
momentum will do things in a certain way
so there's an ordinary kind of way that
you work that out which just says
the the the it doesn't matter what the
momentum is well
yeah in the first approximate sorry it
doesn't matter how many particles are
already there it doesn't matter what the
density of particles is it's just the
amount of
each bounce is independent
okay there are some particles called
fermions which have the property that if
there is a particle already in that
state you can't put another fermion into
that state bosons have the opposite
property they have the property that the
in this formula that determines kind of
uh the sort of the interactions between
these things there's an extra factor of
square root of n where n is the number
of particles that are already in that
state
and that extra factor means these
particles like to all
get together in the same state
and so what happens in a laser
is that uh the i mean laser stands for
light amplification by stimulated
emission of radiation i think i've run
out of time to the point of i'll explain
that another time how that how in detail
that works but basically the idea is
that in a laser all the photons not for
the same reason
as
molecules in a solid are lined up that
has to do with mechanical forces between
them instead the photons in a laser
are arranged to be in the same state
same same frequency which means same
color of laser light going in the same
direction a definite beam going in a
definite direction they're arranged by
quantum mechanical processes
to be
in that same state
and that's that's kind of the analog of
being in a solid phase for atoms in a
material is in light it's coherent light
where all of the photons are kind of
lined up in the same direction with the
same energy so that that would kind of
be the analog of that
and you there isn't
well
there isn't an ordinary analog of
temperature
you could probably
define that let me think about that for
a second
um
yeah
actually you could define that people
don't usually do it usually people say
that lasers are the result of negative
temperatures
for reasons i can explain another time
um negative temperatures in the material
lead to blazers
etc etc etc but but when you think about
a laser
um you can think about a a perfectly
coherent beam of light where all the
photons are exactly arranged in the same
direction same etc
that's kind of like the zero temperature
version and you can think of it as when
there are little deviations from that
there are photons that aren't quite you
know that are in slightly different
states and aren't quite aligned in the
same state you could think about that a
little bit as being like temperature and
people don't usually do that and i'm not
quite sure why certainly could could
think about it that way i mean i think
usually uh one is thinking about it's
just a laser and it's got this sort of
precise alignment rather than how does
it deviate from being a laser and
usually the deviations are measured in
terms of the the way the beam for the
laser
spreads and so on which which could
probably be thought about in terms of
some kind of temperature-like quantity
um all right i think we ran out of time
here um but lots of lots of lovely
questions and i can see many more
uh for
next week
i will probably
not be my usual location next week and
uh
i'll i'll try to do this at the same
time next week might be from a different
location maybe i'll even have a live
audience next week that'd be fun that'd
be different
um in any case um
i look forward to seeing you all uh
hopefully next week if not that the week
after
um and uh remember
uh there is a form where you can
uh send in
questions you'd like me to try and
address
um
and uh
um
yeah i'm
i'm told i'm supposed to i'm supposed to
pitch other things i'm doing uh let's
see on monday i have the next episode
in my walkthrough of my big book from 20
years ago a new kind of science
and
monday i'm doing kind of a walk through
the chapter called two dimensions and
beyond
um
and uh
let's see
um i think as i mentioned at the
beginning
there's now a bot
that's saying what i'm going to be doing
which
uh i don't know i don't know what it
actually looks at
the bot is a bot
um
and uh it's probably looking at my
calendar or something um in any case it
it will hopefully hopefully correctly
and i don't know whether the bot has a
sense of humor and might do crazy might
say crazy things too
um we'll be announcing other uh live
streams and other things that i am doing
um
and uh with that
i should probably disappear
so